The Western Roman Empire collapsed in 476 AD
The microphone was not invented until the 1870s.
It’s a gap.
And so far we still know how the ancient Romans read their Latin
Proof?
OK!
Christian school
Literature class
My teacher is a priest who yelled at his priest F.
As a priest F with a language mind, he has more experience than many of me.
respect--
Everything happened in the morning, and the sunshine in that classroom
Almost to switch the power switch in my mind
Language vocabulary drifted through the classroom
"Consonant", "Italian", and "pronunciation" exceeded my sensor.
A child is talking to the priest over there
As far as I can recall, it’s probably like this.
"Well, that, how do we know what Latin sounds like?
I always think that Caesar's sentence is "vennee veedee veechee".
But some Latin students told me that v is w and c is k. "
"Hey? No.
Please, can you imagine any Italian who speaks "wennee, weedee weekee"? "
I am sitting there, making sure there are some problems.
My first linguistic doubt is about how Latin becomes Romance.
Then why am I suddenly speechless?
Ah, kid, it will take you a few years but I will come back to help you.
We think we know how Caesar’s Latin sounds, but it’s not always true.
We understand because ⋯⋯ sometimes they tell us
Professor Kun Tiliang comes from Spain, a Roman empire, and is a smart person. He moved to Rome,
I was able to survive the crazy "Four Years of the Four Emperors" and established a school of rhetoric.
Then he hates the letter K.
"So, I personally think that K should not be used anymore.
C maintains its strength before all vowels. "
If he says that "C" always has a "K" sound, then it means that C is not like English or Italian.
The pronunciation of the squeaky sound (S).
But this is just the rhetoric of a grammar scholar. Things may be in all evidence
They all come out differently. What is the "R" claimed by a Czech linguist?
Your Latin textbook says that R is a small tongue, and she says it should be a flash.
We only have a little bit of evidence, written by ancient authors.
"Good" in Latin. The first clue they gave us was the letters,
They should be in line with the Latin sound. Did you hear English?
So when we write different vocabulary, like ÁNVS, ANVS and ANNVS, it is
Clues to different readings. "ahh" such as long sound, sometimes
The small "apex" sounds different from the short "ah". Twin tones and monotones
It sounds different.
In the epic of Weijier, the letters that are seen immediately are full.
Precise structure: step. From the steps we can construct the length of the syllables.
This also helps us to prove which vowel is longer and which vowel is shorter.
So some "I", sorry, "ee" is longer than the other "ee".
But take a closer look at the short "ee" on the inscription and you will find something interesting.
Or, can't find it. Because maybe there should be "ee" there, but only "E". why?
Well, this makes sense. If the short "ee" is not only shorter than the long "eeee", even
Have different pronunciations, one is "ihh", close to the pronunciation of "é".
The Romans left many clues as they advanced into foreign languages.
And was attacked by the Germanic tribe. Linguistic ambush. "We want to make a vocabulary, companion!
What do you want? "Give me some wine!" "I want the wall!" Yes, these are Latin vocabulary.
There is also a bad accent. And they make "v" look like "w",
Some of us have some doubts about poetry and word pairs.
So yes, good Latin is circulating, but after the return home, the Roman mob is
Let it go bad! Although the Latin writer noticed, even the entire nation is
Talking about bad Latin, the so-called "popular Latin" is especially funny.
But bad Latin can only be considered a good evidence. Back to Pompeii, before the tragedy, one
Passers-by come here and graffiti, let us know him and his brother forever
I have been here for a tour. Although he drew something inferior. He missed "h" in "here".
Ah, just a small mistake, right?
Then you find a book full of dust, very old, and full of corrections, telling you
Tell you that "old" is "vetulus" instead of "veclus"; "hostiae" instead of "ostiae";
There is also "hermeneumata" instead of "erminomata". Please! It seems that Pompeii brothers file
It is not the only missing H letter.
These errors are some sort of interesting evidence. I mean you probably won’t ask me.
Don't miss writing H, even though people are actually missing H.
But the "heresy" of linguistics finally turned it into a Romance language. they
All can tell us about Latin.
Wait, why is the new language a proof of death? Take a look at the "e" in Spanish and Italian:
They all come from the Latin "e", but also from the short "i", not the long "i". Like these
Inscription! They have more evidence of short "ih" and long "eeee".
Also, "si" is the letter C. The Romance still quite like it, but in
Before e and i, it sounded. In addition to Sardinian. So when most Italians read "vincere" in Sardinia,
"Winning" is "vìnchere". The current pronunciation of Romance is another topic, but historical linguistics
Said that these languages ​​are secretly telling us, "Latin C always sounds like K, but most
It has changed. They gave a thumbs up for Kunming.
Look, little guy, that's why when the Romans said "conquer"
They read ['wɪnkærɛ], and why Caesar's famous saying is /we:ni:/, /wi:di:/, /wi:ki:/(I come, I see, I conquer).
Now when you ask to rebuild the voice, ask the pope to speak
When you are like Caesar, think about the story of Latin living. This is just one part of the whole story.
It’s amazing.
Stay close to us, subscribe to the language!